sentidos
[Música]
nominal
así es como la policía china entró en la
casa de una persona sospechosa de
haberse contagiado de kobe 19 la
situación sucedió en un apartamento en
shanghai donde sus 26 millones de
habitantes se encuentran confinados
desde finales de marzo
conforme a la estricta política china de
cero cobit la gente tiene que quedarse
en casa las autoridades les entregan la
comida y solo salen para realizarse
pruebas pcr
y esta dedicación
si dan positivo son detenidos y enviados
a centros de cuarentena
este vídeo muestra una de esas
detenciones
ah
cuándo
y
hablamos con una mujer que vive en el
mismo edificio donde tuvo lugar esta
escena se enteró de la detención en un
grupo de discusión de residentes
al parecer nuestra vecina se había hecho
una prueba y estaba esperando los
resultados para confirmar que era
negativa para kobe
pero el policía quería enviarlo a un
centro de cuarentena aunque no tenía
pruebas de que fuera positiva le habían
ordenado hacerlo y su nombre estaba en
la lista las condiciones en los centros
de cuarentena no son buenos
las luces permanecen encendidas las 24
horas del día no hay intimidad y en las
instalaciones sanitarias por ejemplo no
hay agua en las duchas la gente intenta
evitar ir a los centros porque la
mayoría de las veces se recupera por sí
mismo en pocos días
[Aplausos]
la situación es muy frustrante porque la
gente siempre ha estado de acuerdo en
respetar las normas de kobe pero
actualmente no hay comunicación alguna
[Aplausos]
el problema es que hay una falta de
claridad sobre las normas y
procedimientos
todo ocurre siendo una base legal clara
no se sabe cuáles son las normas y
aunque se sepa se tiene la impresión de
que no cuentan porque todo depende de
los policías que las aplican cuando
llegan a las casas de la gente
[Música]
tengo patrones
este joven carga una bolsa llena de
hojas de coca en colombia anthoc hay
cientos de vídeos de este tipo grabados
en campos de coca publican jóvenes
colombianos que quieren mostrar su
trabajo diario en este sector aunque
esta planta es ilegal en el país
nuestra redacción habló con uno de estos
jóvenes que cultiva coca en el
departamento de putumayo aunque muestra
azúcar en tick tock decidimos preservar
su anonimato por razones de seguridad
vídeo sentido para mí ir conociendo
gente de otro lado y pues a ese lente de
otro lado no conoce la coca entonces se
interesa en conocerla empecé a trabajar
en cultivos de la coca porque tenía un
pedazo de terreno lo tenía abandonado y
entonces me puse pueda cultivar la coca
en el departamento donde yo vivo la
mayoría de gente
la posibilidad más efectiva de conseguir
empleo tener cultiva mente del acuerdo
que va a quedar el dinero que trabajando
en el supermercado en la batería así
el tema en raspa solo para tener dinero
buen licor buenas hembras
en colombia a cerca de un millón de
personas trabajan en este sector según
la onu la gran mayoría son simples
campesinos que cultivan esta planta por
falta de alternativas las ganancias las
obtienen principalmente los grupos
armados que controlan el sector como por
ejemplo los paramilitares las guerrillas
o los narcotraficantes extranjeros una
industria lucrativa y sangrienta ya que
la coca se utiliza para fabricar cocaína
una droga de la cual colombia es el
primer productor mundial también en este
caso numerosos vídeos de texto muestran
los laboratorios clandestinos donde la
cocaína es transformada en base de coca
y luego en cocaína
y
después de que uno se raspa la hoja la
hoja de coca tiene que llegar al
laboratorio donde tu base de
procesamiento para sacar de lo que es la
base de coca ya al tener el producto
puede ser la base de coca tú la tienes
que entregar a una persona y esa persona
se la tiene que volver a entregar ya los
grupos armados al margen de la ley
si tú no la vendes a ellos te puede
ocasionar a multar con la muerte en 2016
el acuerdo de paz firmado entre el
gobierno y la antigua guerrilla de las
farc incluía ayudas económicas para los
campesinos si sustituían la coca por
otros cultivos pocos de ellos han
recibido la ayuda prometida al contrario
en los últimos años el gobierno ha
intensificado la erradicación de los
cultivos de coca
esto es todos los observadores por esta
semana muchas gracias al castillo del
mono sobrio por prestarnos un espacio
para realizar la grabación de hoy ya
saben que si se quieren poner en
contacto con nosotros todos los datos
aparecen en pantalla sigan con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom hasta pronto